The Joe Rogan experience.
Hey, wait, that's this.
This reminds me of when you talk about
that island, that private island.
Do you know Sentinel Sentinel's
sensible? Our Central Island? Yeah.
Planes still fly over that or no?
Are they not allowed to tell
about it as a restricted airspace?
I don't think it's restricted.
No,
but you can't land there
and you can't circle. Right.
You can't visit. India owns it.
Right. It doesn't, it doesn't.
India control leaves and
it's like 10 mile radius.
I saw a thing online that said a boat
crash there and you could still see on
Google images the remnants of the boat.
Yeah.
They came for the people in the boat too.
And the helicopters got them off the boat.
Right as the people were like pulling up
and Oh, so they lit raps and shit. Yeah.
Fuck yeah, they, they live. But those, the
villages were common for them. Wow. Yeah.
Can you imagine stumbling across a village
they've been fucked with sometime in
the past? You know that a commander
Maurice Vidal Portman. Yeah. Guy. Yeah.
Shout out to a respectable
law on, uh, Twitter.
He has a, a, a giant thread about it.
It may be pinned on the top of
his Twitter page, but explaining,
uh, like one of the reasons why
those people were so hostile. Right.
And it has to do with this British
explorer who was really kinky and, uh,
he went there to fuck. Who knows, we
want to fuck island as what he did,
but people got sick because
of them. You know, this,
I had this Guy Graham Hancock on yeah.
And he was talking to me about, um, uh,
all the different shit
that they're finding in the
Amazon and in South America,
and that they used to be 20 million people
that live in the Amazon and they died
off because of sickness.
They were visited most apparently
Europeans when they came in like the 15
hundreds,
they would tell these incredible stories
about these huge civilizations in the
Amazon. But then when explorers
came back 200 years later,
there was nothing there. And they were
like, this is crazy. They do. They lied.
They must've lied,
but it turns out they didn't lie.
What happened was smallpox ran through
the fucking jungle. And white people.
Everybody.
We did it and then these,
the jungle just overtook the cities and
now they're finding these cities with
something called Lidar.
They use these planes and they circle
over this area or helicopters or whatever
the fuck they do and they shoot
this shit down this lidar.
It's like laser radar and it gives you
a detailed image of what's below the
surface and what's there. And it
shows them all these crazy structures,
all these like uh,
like roadways and irrigation systems
and circles inside of a square.
Like it was villages and cities and the
millions of people probably live there.
I couldn't look at it. That's all
stuff. They're finding that yeah.
And all of it was
swallowed up by the jungle.
They think within like a hundred
years just vanished in the jungle.
Oh cause it's so, so lush and
tropical down there. Dude.
It was one of the most amazing podcasts
I've ever done to listen in to that guy.
Tell this story right after
this one though. No, you are
the best. You're the best.
He's a, this is kind of, well this is
like, this is like the of Atlantis, right?
Like when they started finding,
you started finding more and more land
under in this they found traces of five
drugs including dime methyl trip to mean
on a thousand year old South American
ritual. DMT Baby. That's
like proof positive. Um,
evidence that it least 1000 years
ago they were using Iowasca.
Wow. This was the drug pouch
that was made from Fox snouts.
That sounds so crazy. It
literally look, when you see it,
it looks like they used everything and
the first reason it looks really nice and
knows,
I wonder why they do that with a Fox.
It's probably like some cleverness
somehow that that's what a shaman,
that's like literally what a shaman
is supposed to. That's what the, the,
the definition is supposed to be in
certain cultures, certain cultures.
It's a clever fellow. That's who
the chef, the Shawman is. Okay.
That kind makes sense. They are just
clever fellows. But I mean imagine that.
Like he takes a Fox, that clever little
fucker. I'm going to take his face.
I want to split my drugs in his face.
Only a person would think to do something.
So creepy trucks.
No exact chipmunk cheeks. Yeah, right.
That would be a good move. Yeah.
A little pouch.
Sugar pouches at hangs for your belt.
It's just chipmunk cheeks
while your coins in it.